[Music]
on this wednesday night a desperate
mission off nova scotia
hard-working men just wanting to make a
living
and get back home the search for missing
scallop fishers is
suspended activating emergency plans
ontario's hospitals told to prepare
for even more coveted patients plus the
alberta baby who got the virus when she
was just a few days old
and ended up on a ventilator that was
the scariest moment of my life
record-breaking bust in toronto the
street value of this massive seizure
of drugs and guns and to the moon
a canadian is going where no canadian
has gone before
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we know families across this country are
enduring so much uncertainty because of
covid19 and now
several families in nova scotia have an
added agonizing burden
the search for missing crew members on
board a scalloped fishing boat that went
down
in the bay of fundy has now been
suspended six men were on board
the body of one of them has been
recovered anyone who fishes for a living
knows it is a risky business but hearing
bad news like this
never gets any easier ross lord is in
digby nova scotia tonight
ross well donna despite a second day of
searching these waters
the search has now been suspended with
no indication anyone survived
the company that owns the chief william
solis says there appears to have been an
unknown event
that caused the vessel to capsize the
company notes that no distress call is
known to have been made
the rcmp is now taking over hoping to
recover the bodies of the five
other crew members
ground search and rescue teams inspect
the shoreline near the site of tragedy
volunteers braving the same bitter cold
and vicious winds
as the scallop fishers whose boat went
down early tuesday morning
they're factoring in the bay of fundy's
fast rushing tides
as they look for evidence to continue
looking for articles of
could be vessel pieces any rescue
equipment anything that would indicate
the vessel's name on tuesday searchers
found two empty life rafts
the body of one scala harvester and some
clothing
the other five fishers from the chief
william solis
are still missing
military aircraft are helping with the
search a grim ritual when tragedies
happen in fishing communities
a terrible trade-off for a nova scotia
seafood industry worth billions of
dollars a year
along with lobster the world famous
digby scallops are a big part of that
industry
a harsh reminder of the dangers that our
guys go through
you know every day when they go out
fishing if they don't go out they don't
get paid
as 30-year scallop fisher kim emino
knows all too well
emino knows some of the crew members of
the missing boat and its captain charles
roberts
he says they typically fish for up to a
week at a time
returning to digby when they've caught
enough to make their living
hard-working men just wanting to make a
living
and get back home the chief william
solis was reportedly carrying a full
load of scallops
when emino heard the votes emergency
beacon had gone off
he went out alone to look for survivors
ignoring the treacherous conditions you
don't think about that when you're
thinking about your buddies out there
floating waiting for somebody to come
get them
right i would expect somebody to come
look for me
right what are you thinking about now
[Applause]
what i was thinking about just now was
about the families that have to think
about where their loved ones are
and how they're going to get by without
them
the timing of this is especially cruel
in a year already filled with horrific
tragedy in nova
scotia and after one of the crew's final
catches before christmas
donna all right ross lord
thanks the search for a canadian forces
member missing off the coast of
california has now ended
master sailor dwayne earl is believed to
have accidentally fallen overboard the
navy frigate hmcs winnipeg early monday
his absence wasn't noticed until later
that morning the vessel turned back to
help in the search about one thousand
kilometers off san francisco
earl spent more than 30 years in the
canadian forces
now to the vaccine rollout more
canadians are getting a shot in the arm
this is nova scotia's first person to
get vaccinated danielle sheeves is a
registered nurse she works in a
covid unit at a halifax area hospital
she was one of
about 390 nova scotia healthcare workers
to be vaccinated today
i was honored to be asked to be the
first person to get the vaccine this
morning
i think this is one of the only ways
that we're going to get back to
some some semblance of a normal life and
we'll protect
the public our patients everybody so i
think everyone should
should get the vaccine rollout of the
pfizer biontech vaccine is now underway
in nearly every province in canada
along with nova scotia pei newfoundland
and labrador and manitoba also
administered
their first shots today new brunswick is
expected to begin roll out this weekend
the territories are waiting for approval
of the moderna vaccine which is
easier to transport in ontario
vaccinations are ramping up for
priority groups but it's too late for
people getting sick
now public health officials warn the
situation remains extremely volatile
more than 2 000 new cases were reported
in ontario today for the second day in a
row
43 more ontarians have died that pushed
the province past a grim new milestone
more than four thousand people in
ontario have now died of covet 19.
hospitalizations are climbing two 932
people are in the hospital in ontario
256 of them in icu
toronto public health says the
restrictions are not working to stop the
spread
and more needs to be done ontario
hospitals already over capacity are
being told to activate emergency plans
to clear beds for a surge in more
coveted 19 patients
abigail beeman reports the message to
the public is
the same as it would have been just even
louder to say that
there's real strain on the system at
toronto's humber river hospital
coven 19 patients fill close to half of
the icu
bracing for a further surge they're
making space however they can
in the acute care center also looking at
unconventional spaces to surge into
this memo from ontario health to all
hospital ceos in the province calls for
those in the hardest hit areas
gray and red levels to ensure at least
10 to 15 percent
surge capacity for covid19 patients
within 48 hours
the rest of the province is asked to
plan for the same thing
we've adopted this dimmer switch model
so we want to dim
down elective procedures and surgeries
and other kinds of care that can safely
be deferred
not not canceled but deferred but do as
much of that work as we possibly can
at st joseph's health care in hamilton
they're still deciding whether to defer
elective and non-urgent surgeries but
they're confident they can hit the 15
percent bed
increase target in part through a
satellite site set up at a hotel
by the end of the day tomorrow 30
additional patients will have been moved
so that will be very helpful
we also have a natural slowdown of
surgical volumes over the christmas
break
a christmas slowdown is common across
the board but so is the fear about what
will happen
in january unless we behave
during the holidays we are going to
crumble the system
and the 10 and 15 percent of the beds
will not even help
many hospitals are asking staff to
consider canceling vacations over the
coming weeks
meanwhile the ontario hospital
association held an emergency board
meeting to discuss the potential
surge in hospitalizations the group
calls it a quote far
more serious situation than the first
wave but declined
multiple interview requests to discuss
the state of things
abigail beeman global news ottawa
in alberta the government is preparing
for more patients it's working with the
red cross now to set up a field hospital
at the university of alberta's butter
dome
it will take a few weeks to set up the
care center which could add an
additional 100
inpatient beds this is a purely
precautionary measure
for use if needed in the future
right now there are 749 albertans in the
hospital with covid19
139 of them are in intensive care
the youngest to end up in intensive care
in alberta has been a newborn baby
nora forrest almost didn't make it it is
rare for children to get seriously ill
from the virus but it does happen
and for nora's parents who themselves
got covid19
it was agonizing heather urix west has
their story
it's okay baby it's okay norah
at four days old nora forrest cries but
cannot make a sound
her tiny body relying on life support
all
because of covet 19. that was the
scariest moment of my life
she was born full term on november 22nd
at calgary's rocky view hospital
her parents had taken every precaution
to avoid the virus
but 36 hours after bringing nora home
her mom jada forest realized
she was sick and then i woke up
sometimes so i had like a little bit
fever but more runny nose
and i literally felt like the train just
fixed me
within days the whole family had
symptoms father ben came next then
big sister hazel even cheta's mom who
lives in the home
too we all were getting sick and we all
thought oh hopefully the baby doesn't
get the cold because we thought it's flu
or cold
but nora did get sick spiking a fever so
high that her parents were told to get
to hospital right away
so they rushed it and suddenly like 10
people showed up in the room and they're
poking her checking everything
asking what's going on and then and then
she stopped breeding
we thought that we probably will not be
able to bring her home we're going to
bring an empty car seat which was you
know like when you see the car seat is a
constant reminder that
you know that might be empty and that
was really hard
most kids who get covet do not get very
sick at all
but while severe illness is uncommon it
is not impossible
and there have been hundreds of cases in
canada where kids have been hospitalized
because of covet 19.
we've had zero deaths in children in
alberta there have been
just a small single digit number a
handful of deaths and children across
canada
but definitely
young infants are one group where
there's the risk of ending up in an
intensive care unit and then potentially
longer term consequences of of coba 19.
can you say hi heather say hi hi
hi norah's story has a happy ending
after
almost two weeks in hospital the forests
were able to bring their daughter home
and hazel loves her she constantly tries
to feed her and
give her kisses but the experience has
given the family
a new perspective knowing how close they
came to losing someone
so precious to colvin 19. heather eurix
west global news
calgary a huge bust by toronto police
coming up the massive amount of firearms
and drugs seized in one apartment
plus the prime minister reflects on 2020
and what next year
might bring
this is the biggest seizure of guns and
drugs in a single day by toronto police
57 handguns eight long guns including an
uzi and 15 000 rounds of ammunition plus
cocaine
crystal meth and fentanyl police say it
has a street value of more than 18
million dollars
was all found in a toronto man's
apartment police say
he had no previous history of drugs or
firearms offenses
he now faces 78 charges
the pandemic has been a huge test for
political leaders around the world our
ottawa bureau chief mercedes stevenson
interviewed canada's prime minister to
reflect on 2020 mercedes one of the
topics you touched on is the fate of the
two michaels the two canadians
who have endured more than two years of
captivity now in chinese prisons
what did the prime minister say donna
what the prime minister said caught my
attention
and it surprised me a bit he seemed to
take a more positive tone than what
we've heard from the government in the
past
when i asked if there might be hopeful
news for the families of michael kovrig
and michael spavor before the new year
arrives
certainly hope so we have been working
from the very beginning on this this
will be
their third christmas in arbitrary
detention in china and what their
what their families have gone through is
is just horrific what they've gone
through
uh with an amazing amount of resilience
so is something brewing behind the
scenes well earlier this month an
unconfirmed report said the u.s justice
department
may be cutting a deal with mung wong
joe's lawyers
that could see her return to china that
raised hopes
and canadian officials have long
believed the two michaels were detained
as retaliation for her arrest
so if she returns home perhaps that
could be the trigger point to begin the
release of the two canadians
and mercedes 2021 will bring new
leadership to the u.s
but it won't all be smooth sailing
trudeau and president-elect joe biden
don't agree on the keystone xl pipeline
for one thing is there a clash coming on
that
well it could be the first serious
disagreement the two leaders face
biden has promised very clearly to
cancel keystone xl and he
has surrounded himself with key
administration figures
who share that view but the prime
minister is hoping to change
their minds even if it means asking
biden
to break a major electoral promise in
making that argument to american
democrats and to
to people in general for the past seven
years that the keystone
uh is an integral part of canada and
america's uh
energy security and uh it's an argument
i will continue to make it's
a conversation i had in my very first
chat with president-elect biden
as president-elect and we'll continue
working together
it's been quite a year mercedes how did
the prime minister sum up 2020
a difficult year to be sure donna but
the prime minister said canadians came
together and he's proud of how his
governments performed but like most of
us
he can't wait for it to end here's how
he wished us
a happy new year going hard
and i think that's the most enthusiastic
thumbs up i've seen from the prime
minister in some time
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks you can watch the full interview
with the prime minister on christmas day
on global ahead alberta's dilemma over
orphaned wells deepens during the
pandemic
tens of thousands of inactive oil and
gas wells dot the alberta landscape and
there's concern many of them will be
abandoned by companies that own them
as investigative reporter julia wong
reports the pandemic appears to have
made a long-standing problem
even worse
there are 17 pipelines a couple pump
jacks and two inactive wells on this
alberta property
oil and gas has been here for decades
almost as long as verna and brian
phippin's family
but over the years the blowouts
corrosion and spills have taken a toll
as things happen more and more and more
i begin to hate it i begin to hate the
petroleum industry
there are now close to one hundred
thousand inactive wells in alberta
up more than ten percent from last year
and a jump of more than 25 percent from
just four years ago
and the covet 19 pandemic may be making
things worse
global news obtained this presentation
to the alberta energy regulator board
through a freedom of information request
it notes many operators are shutting
down production
some will likely not ever be able to
restart and
some are not following proper suspension
and decommissioning procedures
we're always worried about bigger issues
get leaks
and general environmental contamination
the orphan well association is funded by
industry
and is supposed to look after wells left
behind governments have also
chipped in we do feel like we're well
situated to deal with this issue at
least here for the short term
the last few weeks the regulator
identified 86 companies that failed to
pay into the industry cleanup fund
it says some later made payments experts
say if more companies go under
the public will have to pony up or the
levy on
continuing oil and gas producers would
have to be dramatically
dramatically increased we're very near
that worst case scenario the alberta
government says it's exploring new rules
to ensure companies can afford to pay
for cleanup
before they drill it will also set new
mandatory targets to reduce the number
of inactive wells
and allow landowners to recommend where
industry should start
we could see some potential for some
further companies falling into
insolvency so we put the tools in place
and again
this is something that previous
governments never did you get into this
business knowing exactly what those
obligations are
you know there we do have a few
defaulting companies that that are
unable to discharge those
herald says defaulting companies are in
the minority
and there are safety nets for them but
for the fitbin family
the changes are coming too late who's
going to look after us
nobody is nobody's looking after us
julia wong global news
edmonton part of the transition to clean
energy is hydrogen and emissions-free
fuel
that can be produced from a variety of
resources including natural gas
and today the federal government
unveiled its hydrogen strategy
it's investing 1.5 billion dollars to
develop a hydrogen fuel industry
it claims hydrogen could cut greenhouse
gas emissions by up to 45 million metric
tons per year by 2030
and it could create up to 350 000 jobs
by 2050. the plan suggests setting up
several regional hubs across the country
where hydrogen fits local needs or
expertise already exists natural
resources minister seamus oregon says
the program is a key part of canada's
goal to reach net zero carbon emissions
by 2050. this strategy provides a
challenge to
all of us to make canada the top
producer of low carbon hydrogen in the
world
the federal government estimates the
global hydrogen market could reach
nearly 12
trillion dollars by 2050.
houston we have a canadian next nasa
includes canada in the next lunar
mission
going to the moon to stay by
2024 and this is how
this all starts when nasa produced this
video about its new mission to the moon
it made sense to have canadian actor
william shatner narrate it but this new
mission is not
fiction it is real and canadians are
going to play a big part in it
mike armstrong on canada's role in the
lunar gateway
[Music]
it has been 48 years this week since
humans last went to the moon this was
apollo 17
leaving the lunar surface jessica
watkins
well nasa unveiled its astronaut team
last week that'll head back to the moon
as part of the artemis missions the
canadian space agency's announcement
tuesday was considerably less flashy
messy lisa it was over a zoom call
but no less important the next
nasa mission to the moon will have an
astronaut with a canadian flag
on his or her shoulder
canada will join the us on the first
crude mission
to the moon since the apollo mission
launching east from kennedy space center
now that first
mission set for 2023 won't land on the
lunar surface
artemis 2's 10-day flight will orbit the
moon testing procedures and equipment
for later missions that will land
but it would make canada only the second
country
to have an astronaut ever have this view
looking back at earth yeah to be honest
i'm totally blown away by this
announcement
gordon ozinski is the director of
western university's institute for earth
and space exploration
he says the ticket canada punched is not
one he
or many other observers expected many of
us were thinking that you know the first
few missions uh
including artemis ii which is where the
canadian was selected would be just all
us astronauts
canada's seat on that trip and another
later down the road
come in return for its contribution to
the lunar gateway
it's an international collaboration led
by the u.s to set up a space station
in orbit around the moon canada is
contributing a canadarm3
i mean there's definitely a lot of work
to be done now it hasn't been decided
which of canada's four
active astronauts will be in the seat
that heads to the moon but if you
consider two of them only graduated from
astronaut school this year
and one has already been to space the
odds are with jeremy hansen
waiting 11 years and counting well
you know it's one of those things like i
i just i don't know
at this point on top of everything else
it takes to be an astronaut
patience is another mike armstrong
global news
montreal and that is global national for
this wednesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is petty harbor
newfoundland and labrador
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
bye